i think i was gonna
drive home in that i probably wouldn't
have made it
but thank god you showed up
almost like it was
[Music]
fake
hey guys pete here this will be my
breakdown for dexter new blood episode
7. the new season is in that constant
stage of build up that we got so used to
in the early seasons of dexter and i
think they're doing a good job of
incrementally revealing details that
tell us where the story is going skin of
her teeth delivered some big answers
brought back a character we've all been
waiting to see and here we are again
thinking how is dexter morgan going to
get out of this situation i'm gonna
recap everything that happened right
after this quick spoiler warning if you
haven't watched episode 7 of dexter new
blood yet then this video won't be for
you and with that out of the way let's
get into it the episode opens right
after the events of episode 6. angela
brings dexter into the cave where she
discovered iris body and they have one
hour to look things over before the rest
of the police get back he examines the
body and the way it was left there and
notices that she was shot from behind he
says it was likely with a rifle and that
she was left in the cave when she was
still alive the rocks were holding her
body down but he found evidence that she
tried to dig herself out tried to get
free he finds a trace amount of skin on
a tooth where it looks like she bit her
attacker it might be possible to recover
dna but he tells angela not to get her
hopes up because the body's been there
for 25 years and there's not much
evidence to go on angela tells him that
she has a theory though kirk caldwell is
her suspect because of his lying about
matt and the timing of calling off the
search right before they were about to
get to the caves we hear dexter thinking
that if angela is right and this was
kurt that did this he has to wonder how
many of his other victims are out there
he talks about the families of the
missing girls not getting answers and we
do see angela go and tell iris's mom
that she found the body he contemplates
where does kurt's journey end with
angela and the police or with me and my
kill table the next morning dex and
harrison eat breakfast things get a
little tense when he talks about the job
which he's getting ready to do for the
first time after he leaves deb points
out that he's drifting further towards
kurt who is probably the second serial
killer father figure in his life and
it's deb this time that says that he has
to kill him she encourages it and he
talks about all the problems that it
could cause it would just be another
secret if kurt disappears then
harrison's crushed he never finds out
who he truly was angela is already
gunning for kurt and building a case so
maybe it's best just to let that play
out and in the meantime he'll just make
sure he's safe deb says good call leave
it to the police what could possibly go
wrong and at first you think she's just
being sarcastic but when you see the
blood stain forming on her stomach
you're reminded what happened when he
left oliver saxon alive so that she
could arrest him after thinking about it
a while he decides to call angela and
tip her off about following molly to the
cabin and he does tell her that's what
he did which is a little strange since
he originally told her and kurt that he
was just out there and saw them when
they get there they notice right away
that someone was moving something
recently and when angela decides to
break in rather than waiting for a
warrant they find that it's been
completely cleared out dex points out
that only someone with something to hide
goes to these extremes and all she can
really say is that they'll try to search
every landfill and dumpster in a hundred
mile radius he says that kurt's a step
ahead of them and she points out that
he's not because he doesn't know they
found iris's body he throws it out there
that her entire case hinges on a 25 year
old dna sample that her boyfriend found
illegally and then he thinks to himself
that he may have to kill him
at the school harrison talks to audrey
he wants to hang out after their night
together but she's put off by him
breaking the kid's arm in the wrestling
match it seems like she wants to talk
about it and try to understand what he's
going through but he just gets
uncomfortable when she brings it up and
leaves there's a funny sequence with
harrison getting ready for his first day
of work washing the trucks it looks
almost exactly the same as dexter
getting ready in his kill room in an
attempt to watch over harrison while the
police are building their case dexter
shows up at the truck stop harrison is
mildly annoyed by this since he told him
not to take the job and after he leaves
kirk comes up to give him a piece of pie
on the house and sits down to have a
conversation it's an intense one where
both of their sons come up and he
mentions how it was snowing the night
dexter took him home from the tavern and
he brings up the idea that it was almost
like fate which sounds kind of strange
but before he can finish what he's
getting at angela and logan show up she
gives dexter a quick look sort of
wondering why he's there and then tells
kurt that he's under arrest for iris he
acts like he has no idea who or what
she's talking about and they take him to
the station where they book him molly
comes in she's excited she wants to work
as a team she wants to get involved but
angela isn't happy that she went against
her wishes and talked to kurt ending up
at the cabin trying to interview matt
she basically sends her away after she
yells at her and after dexter sends a
text asking about kurt she goes in to
interview him she says that he's lying
if he doesn't remember iris because she
shows him the posters from back then and
mentions how she used to restock them at
the truck stop that he ate lunch at
every day plus she's looked at his phone
records she's looked at his computer and
there's no record of a call from matt he
mostly acts calm he doesn't appear
worried at all and is cordial if not
condescending when she brings up that
the dna was a match and how they got the
sample when they swabbed him back in
episode 3 he asked for his lawyer and
shuts it down at the truck stop the guy
who was using matt's cards in new york
city at the hotel comes up to harrison
it gives him a 20 bill to help him move
cargo and as you're watching you see
that he doesn't really need his help
it's really about him giving him this
envelope and asking him to give it to
his dad dexter is there when he gets
home so he gives it to him and we see
him open it alone later and he finds the
titanium surgical screw from matt's leg
inside they foreshadowed this in the
party scene when dexter had to come and
deliver the rifle he saw that he had
this giant scar from the boat accident
and this shows dexter that somebody
knows his secret he goes to let mrs
gross's sheep out so that teddy will get
a call and have to leave the station
then he sneaks into the jail to tell
kurt to stay away from him and his son
and tells him to keep his minions away
because he's seen what he is and he
can't get rid of everything something
always gets left behind kurt says that
we can never erase all of our sins not
even fire can do that and he reminds him
that it was snowing that night before he
drove him home only when he got there he
realized it wasn't snow on his jacket it
was ash titanium doesn't melt so he
found the screw in matt's leg from the
accident inside the incinerator and now
he knows that dexter killed him this was
another intense back and forth between
these two where dexter felt like he had
the upper hand after all kurt's behind
bars but you saw that he was confident
anyways and we'll see a little bit later
that when he tells them that he wants to
make a statement he's put together a
plan to get himself out he starts out by
telling angela about his messed up
childhood and how bad of a person his
dad was and the way he describes him he
was definitely pretty bad he explains
that he used to pick up working girls at
truck stops and beat them up because he
was upset that his mother had left him
we see some flashbacks where he's a
young kid listening to the song runaway
on his record player while this is
happening and that gives us some insight
into his ritual he then tells her that
he saw his dad pick up iris on the night
she went missing but as he's telling her
that we see that it was actually him
just in case we weren't sure if he was
telling the truth he knows that blaming
it on his dad will weaken the dna
evidence since they are family and we
see that iris wanted to leave town and
that she was angry at angela for backing
out of their plan kurt seems to try to
talk her out a bit and when he mentions
that he wants to take her home she ends
up biting him and jumping out of the
truck he pulls out his rifle with the
scope and shoots her as she runs away we
can put the rest together that he must
have taken her body to the caves she was
still alive but he buried her with the
rocks and left her there as he's talking
the d.a comes in and interrupts the
interview we find out that the dna
results were only a 67 percent match and
that means that they don't have a case
that they can be sure to win there's
plenty of opportunity for a good
attorney to raise reasonable doubt with
a jury that means that they have to
release him angela is gutted and he
seems pretty satisfied that he's going
to get away with it like this is the end
after taking harrison to work dexter
sneaks into kurt's office and doesn't
find much beyond a check made out to
elric kane for five thousand dollars
it's dated december 23rd and it's in an
envelope that's the same as the one he
got to surgical screw in according to
imdb the character that gave that to
harrison is elric there was also a shot
where he straightened the plaque that
was hanging on the wall which seems like
it might be important later on his way
out he hears that kurt has been released
and he thinks to himself yep i'm gonna
have to kill him at the tavern molly
comes to talk to angela and she says in
her job you learn to live with
unsatisfying endings angela explains
that she was supposed to go with iris
and that she blames herself thinking
that if she'd gone with her then she'd
be safe she thought that finding her
would make up for it all but she doesn't
feel better molly tells her that she got
some really creepy vibes from kurt so
she understands why she went after him
it was the kind of thing that she tells
her listeners to run away from she
didn't have to do that though because
dexter showed up just in time which in
retrospect is also pretty weird his
excuse about checking on the cabin was
weak angela explains that he followed
her there that he had overheard her
talking to kurt about matt which again
doesn't make sense because he was
sitting far away at the table she does
remember him plugging in his phone
though and they realized that he might
have recorded them but that is also
weird as is dexter sitting with kurt
eating pie after he found out he was
angela's prime suspect first kurt was
creepy and now jim if he wasn't angela's
boyfriend molly says that she would
definitely do a deep dive but she knows
that it's not like he's hiding something
because she's the chief of police when
they leave you can see that kurt is
sitting outside and it looks like he's
watching molly at the truck stop
harrison is taking out the trash when
the moose creek wrestlers show up to try
to beat him up they want to retaliate
for their friend who's going to be out
for the entire season he pulls out the
razor to defend himself and takes a
swipe until dexter shows up and stops
him when the other kids leave harrison
tells him that he's right he's messed up
and he always has been he tells him that
he always had bad dreams nightmares and
when he listened to the podcast it all
came flooding back he realizes they
weren't nightmares they were real now he
says he remembers everything and we see
trinity holding his razor after he
killed rita and leaning down to the baby
harrison telling him they're there daddy
will be home soon so he has the image of
trinity killing his mother imprinted on
his brain he's angry and he thinks about
it all the time he thinks about hurting
people all the time and he goes a step
further to say that he thinks about
doing what he did to mom to other people
he accuses his father of always knowing
saying that's the reason he left and
before dexter can respond he takes off
and jumps in his friend's car and that's
that dexter thinks to himself that he
was wrong that now he does have to tell
harrison everything and as he's getting
into his car elric comes up behind him
and grabs him up and the episode ends
there
so another solid episode in a string of
them a lot of revelations and then a lot
of setup for what's going to happen in
the final few the trinity appearance was
worth the wait they're really playing
with that tension of dexter just needing
to tell him the truth and something
always getting in the way of that
happening dexter is very close to
getting his son killed right now by
killing matt and making the mistake with
the surgical screw he can't really feel
like harrison is safe with kurt around
it's not exactly clear when kurt put it
together but when he came over and gave
him the drone he was feeling dexter out
so if he didn't know before that he had
to start putting it together there he is
certainly coming for him or harrison or
both now and he may go after angela if
she gives him problems considering the
interactions they had when they were
releasing him like i said at the
beginning i think they're doing a really
classic job of ratcheting up the tension
as we near the end of the season each
episode sort of feels like it's the best
one yet and then the next one builds on
it i expected that kurt wouldn't stay in
jail but i wasn't sure that he would be
there for iris's murder either and he's
sort of gonna have to get caught for
something new if dexter isn't able to
take him out which technically shouldn't
be a problem he's been killing a lot of
people for a long time but the ending
sort of turned everything on its head
dexter can't watch harrison because it
looks like he's going to be taken off
the board even if that's only for a
short period of time kurt can really
focus on doing something with harrison
whether it be taking him out or trying
to pull him away from his father he's
really in a good position then if angela
shifts her focus to try to figure out
what's going on with dexter he's gonna
have it coming at him from all sides
it's starting to feel like there will be
a conclusion which is what i hope to see
i made a video about that i put it out
yesterday so make sure you check that
out because everything i was talking
about there seems to be reinforced with
what happened here i'll follow up again
in a couple of days with the trailer
breakdown and some theory talk i mean
things changed after this episode for
sure now that we know that kurt knows
that dexter killed matt now that he got
himself out of jail things are looking a
little bit different so i think that's a
good place to leave things let me know
in the comments what you're thinking
what you're hoping to see and what you
thought about this episode please like
this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon